I was trying to build a short peptide
from scratch in Pinal the other day and
it took me forever to figure out how to
add this carboxyl group right here on
this end the c-terminus right here so I
wanted to share with you what I've
learned since I had trouble finding this
on the pi mol wiki maybe you want to
model a particular amino acid sequence
for yourself or perhaps you're an
instructor creating practice problems
involving amino acid identification this
tutorial will help you build the
sequence you want in Pinal let's begin
feel free to open a PI mol window and
work along with me first let's change
our background to white so it looks good
in a journal or a Word document click
display background and set to white now
click anywhere on the background to get
ready to build in pi mol you can
generate amino acid sequences using the
Builder start with the drop down build
menu to select the secondary structural
element you want to create here under
residue we can select from these three
and let's start with a helix now you can
click alt on your keyboard or the option
key if you're using a Mac plus the one
letter code of the amino acid you'd like
to add to your helix so I'm on a Mac so
option L and we have leucine right here
so we can quickly add amino acids to our
chain
or we can add them manually using the
build drop-down menu build residue
glutamate now I'm using option click to
move this over and I can pinch my
fingers to zoom out a little bit now if
you're using the key command don't stare
at the keyboard while you do this I'm
using version 2.3.4 of Pi Mille and a
few of the amino acids don't work for
example I'm pressing option now and E
and nothing is happening no glutamic
acid so I'll have to go to the build
menu and add this one manually so as a
side note the ones that aren't working
for me with the key command RR e for
glutamic acid I isoleucine and n
asparagine to double check your sequence
go to the display menu and turn your
sequence on we can go to the build menu
switch over to an anti parallel beta
sheet and add more residues to our chain
move my structure over and reorient it a
little bit so you can see so as you
build it'll continue to build along your
sequence here although I'm not quite
sure how to make a turn or anything like
that yet I think you might be able to
place two objects and then connect them
but that's beyond the scope of this
tutorial anyway
so notice on our helix we started by
building from the I got some clipping
going on
we started by building from the
n-terminus over here and that's okay
that looks fine this nitrogen here could
correspond to our NH 3 plus and all is
right in the world
but over on this side on the c-terminus
this is waiting for the next amino acid
so it's just a carbonyl group instead of
a carboxylate and notice this structure
overall looks a little funny we have
this kind of ribbon going along through
our chain and then we also have sticks
this is actually trying to overlay a
cartoon plus sticks so we could just go
to the show menu show as sticks and get
rid of that distracting a little line
there but for now let's delete
everything using the action menu to
right sequence problems for students I
like to use the anti parallel beta sheet
because it's easy to orient the amino
acids in a way that we can see the side
chains clearly so let's set up our new
sequence go to build residue make sure
we're an anti parallel beta sheet and
I'm going to go ahead and use some that
actually work with the key command so
again I'm going to press option or alt
and then we'll do lysine leucine serine
methionine aspartate alanine okay and
for some reason now it's showing up as
lines so let's go back to our show menu
show as sticks since this will be the
view that we want to use now often the
hydrogen atoms are not shown in
renderings like this but building from
scratch
puts the hydrogen atoms on so let's give
the more typical view of this by hiding
the hydrogen atoms this is a typed
command hide hydro
now let me reorient this a little bit
I'm just using my keypad I don't have a
mouse and I'm just clicking on my Mac
option and click and it allows me to
move my structure pinching the fingers
in and out allows me to zoom now our
goal is to add a c-terminus here so
people don't get confused that this is
just ending on a carbon meal so I'll
open the Builder now from this menu
now if this little white rap like
selection thing do you see that right
there if that's missing you may need to
go into the mouse menu and change into
an editing mode so just using my
trackpad the way I'm doing I can use
this two button editing mode and then if
I click anywhere else that'll go away
and if I want to add to this piece right
here I can click and that lets it
highlight up again so I could actually
add on to any other part of this but we
just want to add right here for now so
now with this carbon of the carbonyl
selected I can go in my builder and
click on the CH 4 which will add a
methyl group of course we actually need
this to be oxygen to make it a
carboxylate so click anywhere in the
background but not on the structure that
makes the little white selection tool go
away now click on oxygen in the Builder
it asks which atom we want to replace
and we click on our carbon tada
carboxy terminus built I'll apply the
hide hydro command because notice this
added a little which on the end here and
that's not typically shown so if I click
in the command line I can use the arrow
keys on my computer up and down to
toggle through any of the previous
commands that I use so I can just resis
without typing apply it and we lost our
little H on there we'll close the
builder this is still asking me atoms I
want to replace with oxygen so I'll just
click done over here and now we want to
reorient this so that it's easy to see
the side chains all right
so I'm just clicking and dragging on the
white to move my structure without
selecting anything and we've got this
one here that we really want to show the
branching on okay so I think that's
showing this one pretty well we could
get the gist of our sequence now so
here's our n-terminus c-terminus we can
see all these side chains but this
serine is pretty hard to see
we need to reorient that if we want
somebody to identify this sequence we'll
do this using the mutagenesis wizard so
up in this menu wizard mutagenesis and
select protein if that's one of the
options for you and now it's going to
ask you to pick a residue so this is the
one I want to change so mutagenesis
actually allows you to just move into
different rotamers or you can change the
residue so we're applying no mutation
here but just using these our left and
right arrow keys to move this around so
with the serine residue and that
orientation I think that somebody could
identify all of these amino acid chains
so I'll click apply and my structure has
been reoriented now if we want to
recolor the backbone we'll go up to this
color menu color by element to maintain
our CPK coloring and maybe I'll choose
this salmon color right here and to me
it's really important to make sure that
my image is accessible to colorblind
individuals so I'm going to check this
in a colorblindness simulator I need to
save this as an image file on this is
telling me still to pick a residue so
I'm just gonna click done get that
dismissed from here now I can save this
as a PNG from the file menu I can use
this draw array button if I have it and
this will allow me to save an image to
file or copy it to a clipboard to put it
into a Word document but I'm just gonna
use the command on my Mac to do a good
old-fashioned screen shot and take a
screenshot of this image so now I'll
visit my colorblindness simulator
website Pro anomaly is the most
common form of colorblindness so this is
a really important one to check but you
can check all sorts of different
colorblindness here I'll choose my file
or I can drag and drop it and it opens
right here so I'm in the normal view and
now I can click on my pro anomaly and I
see that you know it looks okay but
we're kind of losing some of the
contrast particular lead to these
carbonyls that are pointing back and
forward it's just a little bit harder to
see the contrast of the red against this
salmon color so I'll go back to PI mole
I actually strongly favored this color
scheme and set to where the carbon atoms
are colored this kind of gray and
everything has some nice contrast there
are some others yeah set 4 has a pretty
good one where it's even a little bit
lighter in the contrast is better now if
we pop this image into the
colorblindness simulator check our
protein Amelie and we can see the
contrast is much much better with
colorblindness color choice can be
important but it really seems to me that
good contrast is key so I tend to have
my carbon atoms in these whites or light
Gray's well I hope you've enjoyed this
tutorial and learn something I research
visual literacy with my nsf-funded team
if you're an instructor teaching
visualization you may want to check us
out at bio Mulvey's org and maybe in the
future you can join us for a
biomolecular visualization workshop
thanks for watching